[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back visualpolitik fans these
days the franco-german axis continues to
lead to europe but now the balance of
power has shifted angela merkel had to
deal with four different french
presidents however with the german
chancellor bowing out french positions
are gaining strength in brussels the
more incisive discourse that the
european union is adopting in foreign
policy is an example of this influence
but above all it is the energy
transition that is at the center of the
eu debate the energy transition and one
key question how on earth can we make
economies grow while accelerating
decarbonisation and reducing co2
emissions
[Music]
and while searching for an answer the
president of france emmanuel macron made
this announcement that meant nothing
less than breaking with the prevailing
political discourse of recent years
objective in particular
carbon and
[Music]
the announcement despite coming at a
time of high energy price tensions was
surprising insofar as the latest nuclear
power plants being built by electricity
de france are causing nothing but
problems so the question is why is
macron betting on nuclear power is the
new generation of nuclear power plants
the solution to climate change and more
importantly for everyone will this
decision have consequences for the rest
of the european union today on
visualpolitik we are going to answer
these questions but first let's take a
look at a bit of history
[Music]
europe's nuclear power
france's relationship with the nuclear
energy goes back a long way the french
scientists henry beckerel discovered
radioactivity and the most significant
research into its properties was carried
out by pierre and marie curie but we
still had to wait several decades to
take advantage of nuclear power as a
source of energy specifically it was not
until 1954 when the first nuclear power
plant in the world began to produce
electricity it was in the soviet union
at that time nuclear power seemed to be
the future so these advances were soon
adopted by other economic powers the
united kingdom the united states and of
course france it was already the 1960s
and most of the industrialized countries
had built at least one experimental
reactor little by little new reactors
were being developed and that is how we
came to the year 1973. by then france
had eight nuclear reactors in operation
in five different plants with five more
reactors under construction and then
then came the oil crisis
[Music]
during the infamous 1973 crisis the
price of oil multiplied by four after
the arab countries decided to reduce
their production at that time most of
the electricity in france a country with
no oil fields of its own was generated
by oil fire powered stations compared to
just over five percent from the first
generation of nuclear reactors
[Music]
therefore the so-called oil crisis was
the key to the activation of the mesmer
plan in march 1974 france presented to
the world the plan with which it
intended to break its complete
dependence on foreign oil the goal was
to become the largest nuclear power in
europe
[Music]
this plan envisaged building 80 nuclear
power reactors in 10 years and reaching
170 by the year 2000 a plan that if it
had been completed would have needed a
whole edition of mega projects however
visualpolitik fans the final execution
was more modest 58 reactors were built
on 19 different sites but in any case
one goal was achieved france is after
the united states the country that
produces the most nuclear energy in the
world and of course for france it is its
largest source of electricity generation
[Music]
practically 70 of french electricity is
of nuclear origin the highest percentage
in the world what's more given france's
standing in the european union its 56
operational reactors contribute
significantly to the fact that almost a
third of the electricity consumed in the
eu is of nuclear origin and of course as
it is an energy that is generated
without emitting carbon into the
atmosphere france wants to promote
nuclear energy to fight against global
warming
and well yes i know what many of you
were thinking well josh renewables also
produce electricity without emitting co2
but of course the issue is that as you
know wind and solar depend on weather
conditions what happens when the winds
doesn't blow
well the answer to that question is
something that we have seen in 2021 all
over europe when even the dirtiest of
energy sources had to be used
germany coal tops wind as primary
electricity source well unlike
renewables nuclear offers a stable
electricity production what's more its
price is barely affected by fluctuations
in the cost of uranium of course as you
will know it is also has its drawbacks
nuclear waste management is one of them
and i'm not talking only about safety
but also about cost for example in
france itself the cost of the segayo
project a deep geological repository for
radioactive waste is now estimated at
around 45 billion dollars a far cry from
the 28 billion initially forecast a huge
investment which however is only the tip
of the iceberg
the mesmer plan led to approximately 80
of france's nuclear reactors being built
between the late 1970s and the 1980s
with a useful life of 40 years this
means that either we invest now in their
renovation so that their continued
operation is guaranteed or we have to
face their decommissioning either option
would cost france tens of billions of
dollars
[Music]
specifically two edf estimates the
decommissioning of the reactors would
cost about 85 billion while the option
of updating and overhauling the plants
in order to continue operating for a few
more decades would amount to about 50
billion dollars and it is the latter
that the french government has finally
opted for but take note because for the
moment france is regulated by law that
its nuclear capacity will never exceed
63.2 gigawatts so unless there is a
legislative change any new reactor which
is what the french president has
announced would mean the closure of an
old one that remains to be defined in
any case there is another interesting
question the french nuclear industry has
had a lot of problems in recent years so
the question is is it really ready for
the macron plan listen up
hard times
[Music]
in order to talk about nuclear energy in
france we have to look at three letters
edf the acronym for electricity de
france we are talking about the public
company that owns the french nuclear
power plants and supplies electricity to
france as if it had a virtual monopoly
it also owns framitone the nuclear
reactor business that the company
acquired in 2018 from ariva another
state-owned company that was forced to
restructure in the face of the problems
the french nuclear industry has
undergone over the past decade
in 2016 france's nuclear regulator
ordered 21 reactors more than a third of
edf's nuclear fleet to be shut down
after arriva acknowledged defects in 400
parts manufactured since 1965 and used
in the steam generators inspectors were
concerned about high levels of carbon
found in steel from the le croissant
forge with a risk of steel fractures in
the event of a sudden change in
temperature
what happened then was a good
illustration of what could happen if
france suddenly gave up its nuclear
plants thermal power plants started
burning coal at a rate not seen since
the 1980s but wait a minute because
before we even consider the atmosphere
the slowdown in atomic generation was
felt in the wallets of the french
the price of electricity shot up by 40
but take note because it also rose in
many of the european countries to which
france exports its generated electricity
in 2017 things settled back down but the
joke did not come cheap the french
state-owned company estimated the impact
on its accounts of the closure and
repair of the plants at over a billion
dollars worst of all if this incident is
already serious in itself the big
headache that still plagues edf today is
the european pressurized reactor the epr
a third generation pressurized water
reactor that at the beginning of the
century was presented as the star
project of the french nuclear industry
years have passed and currently there
are only two eprs in operation they are
in china and one has already been shut
down between 2022 and 2023 other eprs
are scheduled to start operating in
finland and france specifically at the
flamenville nuclear power plant i could
tell you about all the problems that the
flamenville epr has had but it would be
better if the french minister of economy
bruno la marie told you
about
[Music]
nuclear forces
as the minister said all these problems
and cost overruns have been a serious
blow to france's reputation in the field
of nuclear energy years ago the united
kingdom was the main interested party in
continuing to invest in nuclear energy
and installing the eprs of the french
state-owned company things are different
today yes a project has been approved
but not surprisingly the british are
losing the desire to place more orders
[Music]
the two epr reactors slated to expand
the hinckley point nuclear power plant
are several years behind schedule and
millions in cost overruns their cost has
risen to 30.5 billion dollars and they
will not enter service until 2026. the
approval of two more edf epr reactors
for the size world plant is still up in
the air it seems that in the end they
will be inclined to give the green light
to the project after 10 years of debate
meanwhile the uk and rolls-royce have
just announced a 528 million dollar
investment to develop and design a new
generation of smaller nuclear reactors
we are talking about the smr small
modular reactor with a power that does
not exceed 300 megawatts compared to the
more than 1 000 megawatts of
conventional reactors the interesting
thing is that rolls royce assures that
smaller will be synonymous with fewer
problems
smrs are expected to be cheaper and
faster to build than existing reactors
their cost is estimated at 2.9 billion
dollars with expectations of a future
reduction to 2.38 billion dollars the
smrs are designed to be produced from a
factory and then transported to their
final location their construction which
would take three to four years promises
to be simpler than epr reactors which
take more than 10 years to complete
[Music]
france is also keeping a close eye on
smr developments
[Music]
a month before announcing the
construction of new reactors macron
pledged an investment of over 1 billion
dollars for the development of these
smrs there has been some confusion
because some media went so far as to
link the two announcement however it is
far from clear that this is the case it
is in fact very likely that the macron
plan corresponds more to what was set up
by a report commissioned by his own
government that was leaked in 2018.
nuclear a report recommends the
construction of six new eprs these six
eprs are expected to cost a third less
than the flemanville epr and 56.5
billion dollars is expected to be enough
to build them all the aim would be to
take advantage of economies of scale edf
claimed that its next eprs will benefit
from cost reductions as more copies of
the same design are built an advantage
that the current projects have not been
able to take advantage of at least this
is the theory for it to become a reality
technological developments will be
necessary but more importantly france
will need to succeed in the battle it's
waging in brussels and this is another
key point welcome to the bureaucracy of
the european community
quid
the european union is about to take a
vital decision to tackle the fight
against climate change the matter under
discussion is the so-called taxonomy i'm
sure many of you know that taxonomy in
biology is responsible for classifying
animals and plants according to their
characteristics well what the european
commission is trying to do here is to
decide whether energy sources are
classified as environmentally
sustainable
[Music]
the idea is that taxonomy of energy
sources will become a guiding principle
for the european union in deciding which
industries can be subsidized the
taxonomy is also intended to guide
financial markets in assessing which
energy sources are worth investing in so
the future is at stake whether it's
access to subsidies and cheap capital or
much more complicated financing if
excluded
[Music]
as you can imagine france is fighting
with all its might to get nuclear energy
into brussels plants and the most
important thing is that they are not
alone along with france bulgaria croatia
slovakia slovenia finland hungary poland
the czech republic and romania have
taken a stand in addition these
countries were also supported by the
netherlands and sweden at the last
council of energy ministers we are
talking about 12 of the 27 members of
the european union but hold on a minute
because other countries are not ready to
roll out the red carpet for nuclear
energy
the opposition group is led by germany
which in 2022 will complete the nuclear
shutdown it announced after the
fukushima accident it is joined by
austria luxembourg denmark portugal and
spain and in fact what berlin is doing
is fighting for natural gas to be
classified as environmentally
sustainable because it emits less co2
than burning coal which is currently one
of its main sources of energy now the
ball is in the court of the european
commission which obtained from the
european institutions a delegated act to
define the framework of the taxonomy and
what does the commission think this is
what president ursula van der leyen said
at the end of october it's obvious that
we need more renewable and clean energy
alongside this we need a stable source
nuclear
and during the transition of course
natural gas and this is why as we've
already stated as a commission in april
we will come forward with our taxonomy
proposal
this taxonomy proposal will be presented
as a delegated act there are only two
ways for it not to go ahead either a
majority of the european parliament or a
qualified majority of the european
council will vote against it this does
not look like any easy task the question
is will brussels be prepared to stand up
to belin
[Music]
so everything indicates that we will
find ourselves with a quid pro quo
agreement in other words something in
exchange for something you know germany
gives in on one side france gives in on
the other the european commission will
classify both gas and nuclear as
environmentally sustainable and everyone
will be happy made in brussels diplomacy
in its purest form but now the question
is over to you do you think france will
finally get brussels blessing for
nuclear energy and would you like your
country to implement a plan to build new
nuclear reactors as well you can leave
your answers in the comments and as
always if you found the video
interesting please like it don't forget
to subscribe to visualpolitik and all
the best i'll see you next time
[Music]